[موسيقى]
انا ما بحب زعيل حدا ابدا
اوقات الدنيا بتوجعني
وساعات بتعاند وياي
لا بخاف وحاخاف ازاي يعني
دايما مطمن طول ما انت معايا
طبيبه نفسيه تاثرت خلال الحرب العالميه
الثانيه بقوه التعاطف والمرونه للروح
الانسانيه وفي عام
1969 عرضت نموذجا معروفا باسمها عن مراحل
الحزن الخمس من خلال هذا النموذج ارادتروس
التحدث بصوت عال عن مشاعر يمر بها الانسان
امام صدمه تهز سلامه النفسي
المراحل الانتقاليه في منحنى التغيير لقبل
الروس تبدا بصدمه تؤدي الى الانكار بعد
ذلك يتملكون الغضب ثم يبدا التفاوض مع
الذات في حوار من طرف واحد نريد الخروج من
الازمه ولكن بلا اي مجهود ثم نقع في
الاكتئاب ويبدا الحزن والياس وكل الافكار
السلبيه بالهجوم مره واحده ولكن التقبل هو
بدايه الحل مرحله الغضب
هي مرحله بتغضب فيها الام من نفسها
ومن حبها لابنه تشعر في الكره يعني هي نحن
ترتقي الام انه هي بتكره ابنها ولكن في
الحقيقه في علم النفس هي مرحله الغضب في
قبل الراس الغضب من نفسها لانه هي عم تشعر
بهيدي المشاعر واللي هي للاسف طبيعيه لو
عنا نحن الوعي النفسي والثقافه النفسيه ما
كانت حتجلط حالها